how many of you have come here to  receive some financial freedom over the  next two days I want you to step right  out of your comfort zone but let me tell  you something when you just step out  welcome to glory are you ready yes yes  what some say is the network is the most  important thing and I think that's  something you get from bra weekend like  this you meet 200 like minded people all  going on the same adventure that's it's  exciting stuff that will has a very very  big heart and I can see that he's got a  heart to actually empower people and I'm  leaving feeling empowered feeling  blessed bubbling with confidence  [Applause]  [Music]